- [Man] Cool, thank you
so much for your time.
- Thank you.
DRock.
I haven't been inspired to make a rant
one-off video in a long time,
but some of the best ones
ever have come in in LA,
and here I am again.
Just, enough.
Fuckin' enough.
Enough!
Like, living by somebody else's rules
is a humongous mistake.
I've just literally sat
down with five people
under the age of 27,
and it's so fucking refreshing.
It is so refreshing.
If you have not jumped on the bandwagon
of doing exactly what
the fuck you wanna do,
which is skiing for the next three years,
or working at a job that's
not what your parents want,
or what society wants,
this video is just called Enough.
Enough.
Make this little fuckin'
one, two minute video,
it depends on when I finish,
the piece of content that
gets you to fucking stand up
and take life by its throat.
Do something.
Stop being fucking scared.
Stop letting the way you were raised,
the fear as an offense, take that away.
Let me be the person.
I'll take the blame.
I loved that some of
my employees are like,
"My parents don't love
what you're saying."
Good, fucking parents,
because if you are playing defense
and if you are living a
life where your kids' lives
are the way you're being fulfilled,
you're a fucking loser, parents.
And so, enough.
Enough parents imposing their way.
You want your kids to
be happy on your terms.
Enough.
The kid that's sitting right now at a desk
and saw this on a feed,
and you hate your fucking job?
Fucking enough!
Stand up, get the fuck
out of here, and do you.
Live your life.
You got one fuckin' life.
Do something about it.
- It's like, so hard when you do this.
(Gary laughing)